the jurogan experience here's what
freaked me out and it didn't seem to
bother a lot of people
the bidens administration the biden
administration blocked the release of
the jfk papers yeah jfk was shot in
1963. how weird is that they're like
nope people are still alive
some people
that would be [ __ ] are still alive
that tells me
the government killed some shady [ __ ]
going on that's what that tells me yeah
that doesn't tell me that the the mafia
killed kennedy or the russians killed
kenny or the cubans killed kennedy that
tells me the government probably had
that [ __ ] something yeah they're
hiding something
yeah it's
1963. that [ __ ] happened four years
before i was born it's 58 [ __ ] years
ago yeah and still got to still hide it
not yet not yet not yet hold it yeah
wait another 25 years unbelievable it's
crazy that they could even justify that
that someone could
keep
historical information that's relevant
to our understanding of how the country
really functioned in 1963 they keep that
from us because it must be relevant to
how the country still functions today it
must it must have some bearing president
being killed yeah and we can't know all
there is to know about it right what do
you know you [ __ ]
yeah i don't even i want to know that
more than i want to know about ufos
i wonder what did you [ __ ] do yeah
what the [ __ ] did you do alan spector
i don't know who that is arlen specter
um
both of them [ __ ] both of them he was
one of the guys that was on the warren
commission report i think it was his
idea for the uh i believe
see if this is right i think he's the
guy who came up with the idea for the
single bullet theory
which is the dumbest [ __ ] theory in
the like your guy who shot a lot of
rifles
when bullets hit bones they get [ __ ]
up oh yeah that bullet was pristine
and they found it in the gurney oh look
magic on connelly governor texas
connelly's gurney they found this magic
bullet
that they think did all the damage to
kennedy and to him went through two
people broke bones and it was not
mushroomed out or anything no not even a
little you never seen it i haven't oh
you're in for a treat generally credited
to him that's what it says
what's up yeah generally credit to him
is what this says i was trying to find
carl inspector yeah arlen specter's the
guy he was a creep during the bush
administration i remember like listening
to him talk on tv and then when i found
out that he was a part of the warren
commission that actually came up with
the single bullet there i was like oh
so look at that bullet
that's it exactly like as a hunter
yeah as a guy who's shot bullets when
you look at that you're like there is no
[ __ ] way and i've had arguments that
people say actually that's a that's not
a good photo if you look at it from
another angle you know you could see
that it has some distortion i'm like
shut the [ __ ] up every bullet i've ever
seen that's been in an animal is
mushrooms that's how they perform they
mushroom out they and there's a there's
a fine line between
basically coming apart where the the
damage would be
dissipated
or and then mushroom perfect none of
them look like this though zero yeah
there's other photos of it where it
shows that it's slightly distorted yeah
that's not even right but the re like
there there's a good somebody actually
tried to say that to me no no you should
look at it from this angle like i'm like
still nothing you don't know anything
about guns you need to shut your [ __ ]
mouth because that's something that was
shot into a swimming pool that's what
happened there yeah see that's what okay
that that was looks like well look at
that they're even work that was more one
of the bullets
so that must be one of the but that's
possible yeah that's possible but yeah
like modern but other thing we have to
think of is maybe modern technology the
bullets that we have is better than the
bullets they had back then but either
way there's no
[ __ ] way here goes every bullet shows
signs of damage uh
exerting force breaking bones damage to
the initial shooting except the magic
bullet
yeah there's no [ __ ] way and they had
to come up here's the thing about the
this is the thing about the theory like
by the way i have
lost months of my life studying the jfk
assassination yeah i really have i've
spent so much time reading books on the
js jfk assassination
but one of the reasons why they had to
come up with this theory that this one
bullet did so much damage is they had to
account for three gunshots
and once they found out that a bullet
had hit an underpass and it had chipped
the curbstone and ricocheted up and hit
this guy
so the guy had to be treated at the
hospital for a ricochet from the gunshot
so they knew that that that was one
bullet that did not hit kennedy it hit
the curb stuff so there's two yeah and
so one bullet blows a hole through
kennedy's head and so they had to come
up with another bullet that went through
his they went through his back
and went into connelly through his wrist
and i believe it wound up in his thigh
yeah this is how they they think the
bullet went which is just and people say
no no you have to take into account that
kennedy was in an elevated position
listen bullets do wacky things when they
go into animals and i i was talking to a
guy once that told me
in the war that they shot a guy in the
head and the bullet came out of his eye
going forward like it ricocheted off the
back of his skull and
yeah he goes bullets do wild things when
they hit bones and ricochet off stuff
but
they don't take turns no they don't take
turns like that there's a reason why the
bullet would ricochet inside inside
someone's head and then come out yeah
like the initial impact is slightly
slowed down it bounces off the back of
the skull and then comes out you
probably clip the eyebrow or something
coming in
but either way they don't come out
looking like that no not after they did
all that [ __ ] and there was more damage
there's more rather fragments inside
connolly's body more bullet fragments
they found in colony connolly's wrist
that were missing from the bullet they
just should have immediately discounted
that bullet and said who gave you this
bullet who the [ __ ] are you yeah where's
this bullet come from for real you're
under arrest yeah you're under arrest
because i want to know where you got
this [ __ ] bullet and like you're
you're gonna start talking why can't we
see that information yeah that's in
there yeah watch the entire episode for
free only on spotify